Asian stereotypes and jokes are so
played out and it's the same [ __ ] that
we've heard for the last 50 years like
miss me with that it's so boring at this
point we describe American food though I
just I just thought of hamburgers and
like yeah meatloaf and mashed potatoes
and stuff so I'm like of course Asian
foods better than that I was just denied
Asian food for a long time my mom wanted
to be Caucasian she wanted me to grow up
as a white person and I think I was
maybe 10 or 11 when I truly like
experienced Korean cuisine like oh my
god this is amazing what's she saying I
find really common cuz when I grew up
you know my parents were both people
from Vietnam like they wanted us to
assimilate as much as possible and not
being made fun of so I love ated through
to - I am but I'm from Texas so I grew
up in like chicken-fried steak and
biscuits and all kind of stuff so I
[ __ ] love American food
[Music]
my dad doesn't care he's happy no matter
if I'm happy my mom never specifically
said it but it was almost like if I
don't bring home a Korean or a Caucasian
which is her preference like I don't
know if she's gonna do so I don't know
what will she kind of push away a little
bit from me and I don't want that my
parents at one point in time we're very
happy like you need to marry like a
Vietnamese person but as I got older I
understood why for them because it's
more about we just want to be able to
relate to the person that you're
actually with so we can talk to them too
for me it's really interesting because
I'm actually married to a black woman I
am Chinese Malaysian but I grew up with
a white father like white people were
definitely always an option but then you
know other groups of people it's like
whoa we're not really sure that they're
like that great that often seems to be
the case it's like you can date white or
Asian and everyone else off the table
for some reason
[Music]
are funny i feel like a weight's
somewhat disagree my head is like
stereotypes are a reflection of
perceived behavior and also I write
comedy and so I'm constantly thinking of
ways to maybe subvert a stereotype to
get a laugh I feel like it's always
dangerous though because you never know
if the joke is going to be perceived as
like oh they're making fun of the
stereotype or they're reinforcing this
stereotype but even then you're saying
like the stereotype itself is not funny
but your subversion of it is okay so
maybe I'll move down I think I'm just
like tired of like Asian stereotypes and
jokes are so played out it's the same
[ __ ] that we've heard for the last 50
years in like American culture then like
missed me with that it's so boring at
this point I don't find it funny well I
totally understand from another point of
view how that's absolutely inappropriate
for from a personal level I'm not
offended I'm not hurt some of them are
actually yeah that's kind of true what's
an example I guess yeah again you know
like for instance me as a Korean like if
I were to say something about like how I
feel like a lot of Koreans behave like
Koreans love kpop like boy bands it
could be funny and it's not necessarily
an offensive stereotype but the growing
up of like Asian men have small penises
and all sorts of other emasculating kind
of stereotypes those kind of stereotypes
play into like why can't I be the love
interest because I have a small penis
but I don't actually know that and why
does it matter well you're talking about
is like a stereotype that's been put
upon Asians by non-asians if we Asians
want to talk about like subcultures in
Asia and like make fun of [ __ ] totally
down might find it funny the Seattle
joke is totally I guess like when you
say when when the statement is Asian
stereotypes are funny I'm often thinking
about Western
stereotypes about Asians and like no not
funny you say it has it easier I think
it discounts the amount of work that's
gone into building up building those
communities out people working up
towards you know becoming professionals
or white-collar professionals like I
don't think they have it
Asians have it easier I think many
Asians have just fought harder I don't
I'm not saying the other communities
don't I just think that I think they
have earned it I think that part of like
how white supremacy works to kind of
like cover up to say like well if this
one group of minorities is doing so well
then there can't be racism in this
country we as asian-americans have to
understand that we are props for white
supremacy when we buy into the idea that
all of this stuff that we've gotten is
purely through our hard work I do think
Asians who haven't either just because
we're not portrayed so negatively yeah
we don't have as many like overtly like
negative stereotypes that are like
thrown at us
you know I mean like you look at
immigration and like nobody's freaking
out about Asians coming into the country
which I feel like it's just been
interesting to me to see especially also
like Asian Americans that are okay with
it because it's not them right now and
that sense I'm like oh we must have it
easier because we're not concerned about
what's happening to other people
super conflicted on this woman I went to
the motherland maybe like five years ago
and I thought that it was just gonna be
like so much fun and they were gonna
like be accepting and for the most part
they are but when I went there I
realized like I'm not from here like it
was really pretty obvious I mean I
definitely want to connect to the
culture that I was born into but also a
huge part of my identity is my queerness
and in Malaysia LGBTQ people definitely
don't have the same legal protections if
they have any protections at all and so
that is painful to know that if I went
back I wouldn't be accepted it's a funny
thing that happens when I go back to
China just like the feeling that I never
get here which is like when you walk
onto a public street you feel like
you're not identified by what you look
like which is amazing but that being
said like I feel culturally I'm American
I love being here and I think that being
like an individual with freedom is like
part of who I am in the sense that I
wouldn't necessarily fit in in China and
I feel like so much of the time we're
like asked to be like well are you Asian
are you American it's like not like
amazing American I don't think we have
to be that for this
three-two-one
[Music]
yeah it's important to me what you think
I mean like I think about this a lot is
like sometimes I forget
then I'm Asian and then like it's kind
of jarring to be reminded that I am and
so like were you raised like with strong
cultural values um I was raised I'm a
military brat and so even though I grew
up in Korea it was on the military base
and so it's like an American high school
in like a small American city in the
middle of Seoul me and my brother were
usually the only Asian kids so I
remember kind of like do I want to stand
out as like the only Asian kid or do I
just want to be another one of the kids
I think there can be balance in that
that was the biggest problem I had
growing up is that I didn't know I
wanted to be American so bad I thought I
had to choose a side and then eventually
I was like look both are part of who I
am but what his further this strongly
agreed part is that I have a
three-year-old child he's half chinese
half Vietnamese and I don't want him to
live with the confusion that I grew up
with for me like it actually I feel a
lot of pain still and a lot of grief
because when we moved to the US and you
know this was like in a time so where
you need to speak to your kids in
English they have to just know English
and anything else will confuse them so
my mom stopped speaking to me in Hakka
and I forgot that language and we also
didn't really celebrate any cultural
traditions you know Chinese or Malaysia
or Chinese Malaysian I have no idea what
that really is
and so my culture is important to me but
I'm still like trying to find my way
back to it like you grow up you're like
socialized to fit in right it often
means casting aside like the culture
that you grew up in fact we're all
experience it to some degree of like hey
should I like look into like where I
came from or it's a great thing if you
can be proud of where you came from I'm
glad that we're connecting to that
so fun can I be friends with all of you
[Music]
and if you strongly agree subscribe and
let us know II thought in the comments
below see you next time